Alex asks Gary do you consider it
possible to hustle the way you do
anywhere outside of the United States
Alex this is a ludicrous question it is
complete I don't do we know where Alex
is from and you can look it up real
quick while I'm answering this question
alex is a ludicrous question this is
this question pisses me off so much that
started to start to show with it as
Steve is looking the thought and nature
of like people saying well America is an
entrepreneurial paradise is the same
conversation that's happening within
America of like to be great in tech you
need to be in San Francisco like no good
businesses are made outside of Silicon
Valley that is just asinine let me just
remind everybody that Facebook was
invented in Boston all right and the
home of the Patriots but like you know
like like I mean it's crazy for me when
people debate this of course you can
your country is not the variable of your
hustle my friend now the environment and
like entrepreneurship is glorified in
the US the UK wants to be more reserved
differently you know China's got a home
version of entrepreneurship yes does the
environment affect it of course my
parents growing up in Soviet Russia
where there was no business of course
they were affected by that but your
hustle your work ethic your drive is not
predicated on your zip code oh crap wait
subscribe do I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe